you know I have to confess I have always
assumed that our thoughts are
constrained by the limitations of the
language that we use for example I'm
very interested in consciousness and
it's always struck me that people who
use languages like Sanskrit have have a
much richer texture in which to look at
the various nuances of consciousness and
I know that you take a different point
of view I think about language yeah I
don't think we that we think in in
language or thinking words I think we
think in visual images we think in
auditory images we think in abstract
propositions of what is true about what
and I think that a language is a way of
communicating thoughts of getting them
out of one head and into another by
making noise I think that even if you
look at language itself you see that
there's got to be something underlying
the words themselves because words can
be ambiguous so if you take one of those
unintentionally ambiguous newspaper
headlines like stud tires out which was
in a New Hampshire newspaper when they
banned stud tires but most people give
it a different interpretation the fact
that there can be two ideas underlying
the word stud for example or underlying
the word tires shows that words and
thoughts can't be the same thing well
isn't it considered pretty much of a
truism for people that different
cultures have more words for some things
that are important to them I mean we we
talk about the Eskimos for example
having many words for snow right and
even that is really bit exaggerated
there's a famous essay called the great
Eskimo vocabulary hoax where someone
actually went to a dictionary of the
Eskimo language and counted the number
of words for snow and the first
dictionary they picked up had a
following number of words for snow not
400 200 not 102 now that was a pretty
stingy dictionary and if you go to
slightly bigger ones you can come up
with maybe a dozen maybe 20 but if you
think about it English has a lot of
words for snow too we've got avalanche
and blizzard and hardpack and powder and
sleet and slush and we're not really
that far behind the Eskimos
there's
to deny the point that if you're an
expert in something you're gonna have
more jargon words for it but I don't
think it's that you have all these
jargon words and you think more thoughts
or more finally discriminating thoughts
I think if you know a lot about
something you invent the words to
express them and I think the fact that
we invent slang we invent jargon we
invent new figures of speech when we
need to show that we have the idea first
and we think to ourselves how am I going
to quote this in words so I can make it
clear to some other person
well language of course is more than
just words a language has a cadence it
has certain sounds and pitches and
Timbers don't you think these things may
may affect the environment in which we
think well those are certainly what make
for great literature and poetry and
prose and artists and writers take
advantage of those things to get across
a certain emotional effect and that's
why great poetry and great literature is
often very hard to translate because
even if you translate the meaning you're
not getting the the resonances of the
sounds you might have like a harsh
staccato set of stones sounds in one
language and their exact translation
might be something very mellow and
smooth and so you might lose that extra
layer of meaning that resonates with the
literal meaning but the fact that you
can translate it all when you think
about it shows that there's got to be
something other than words because what
would it mean for two sentences in in
different languages to be translations
of each other if not for the fact that
both of them have the same meaning where
the meaning isn't exactly the same as
either string of words we translate yeah
it's obviously not like one of those
phrase books where it's how do I get to
the train station and then you find the
equivalent in Hungarian because if you
know two languages you can translate an
unlimited number of sentences there's
got to be something I think under
underneath it something like a set of
propositions that don't really have
sounds that don't have any left-to-right
linear order the way language does but
there is a set of where a web of
connections between concepts and there
are also connected with other aspects of
experience with visual images with body
sensations
well if we were to follow that line of
thinking it would seem to me that one
might say that a person who has no
language at all could still think could
still have thoughts and I think that's
true in fact I recently there have been
a number of techniques that scientists
have used to try to tap the minds of
creatures that don't have language we
now know that babies for example before
they begin to talk have a fairly
sophisticated understanding of the world
around them they pay attention to
objects they make predictions about how
objects will behave what will fall what
won't fall what can pass through what
how people behave babies clearly are
making sense of the world and that's
before there they're saying a word
animals - I think there's a lot of good
evidence that many non-human animals
engage in some form of thought even
though obviously they don't have the
words and even people with words if you
look at the autobiographies of great
scientists and and authors and poets and
sculptors one thing that runs through
all of them is that they say that their
moments of inspiration often come from a
vivid visual image and that they then
have to struggle to find the words to
express that image not only in the
sciences like Einstein who who claimed
to have come upon his insight about
relativity theory by say imagining what
it would be like to be in a plummeting
elevator and then to take a coin out of
your pocket and try to drop it often
novelists will say that the first thing
idea for a novel will be a scene with
people in the scene and then they
struggle for the words to express it yes
so I think that aspect of experience
jives with what the science of mind has
recently found out namely the language
is a very rich part of the mind but only
one part well I suppose it's
incontrovertible if you look at the
biographies of autobiographies of
creative people that they described
their breakthroughs their intuitions
coming to them in many different forms
other than other than normal language
but when we look at babies or when we
look at other animals many critics of
this research would say we have to be
care
not to project to anthropomorphize or or
to read more into the data than is
actually there ya know that that's
certainly true and you can't just look
at a baby guess what it's thinking and
leave it at that but they're not the
techniques are very clever and they
involve indirect ways of looking at say
the baby's eye movements what the baby
is staring at and controlled displays to
try to figure out what's what's going on
in the baby's mind and babies might even
be able to keep track of number they
might even do a simple form of
arithmetic they seem to know that 1 + 1
is 2 these are things that you don't
just get by punches but by seeing how
long they look at various kinds of
displays and what surprises of them and
what bores them you seem to be
suggesting then that the mind has a
language of its own independent of the
language that the mouth uses yes right
you can think of it as mentally mentally
the language of thought and I think
speaking is almost like translating
mental ease into English or Japanese and
understanding it's almost like
translating English or Japanese into
mental ease depending of course on which
language you actually speak but I think
that's why we can understand each other
why we can do we can translate why we
can coin new words when we need them if
words and thoughts were the same thing
it would be impossible to coin a new
word where would it where would the
impetus to coin a word come from if you
didn't have some idea that you needed to
express and also when you're speaking
and writing you are people often have
the sense that they didn't express
themselves properly they'll say oh no
that isn't what I meant to say don't
misunderstand me what came out wrong
what I really meant to say was
such-and-such or when you're writing you
get frustrated and you you tear up the
paper and you say darn that sentence
wasn't what I meant I know what I want
to say but I just can't put it into
words and I think there's something real
behind those that that intuition